[Música]
hace 12 años nadie se imaginaría que una
serie de protestas multitudinarias
terminarían en una guerra civil unas
protestas pacíficas que pedían un cambio
de rumbo político en Siria pedían el fin
del Clan al azar que estaba al frente
del gobierno de ese país en las últimas
décadas y pedían elecciones derecho a
elegir y a otros aspectos que ante los
ojos de los ciudadanos sirios podrían
mejorar su vida diaria y también el
rumbo del país pero este reclamo terminó
en violencia y dando origen a una guerra
civil en la que se involucraron
diferentes actores internacionales al
día de hoy sigue siendo una de las
mayores crisis humanitarias del mundo de
acuerdo con el último reporte de
humanitaria needs overview for Siria más
de 15 millones de personas dependen
todavía de la ayuda humanitaria para
poder cubrir sus necesidades básicas en
ese país de acuerdo con el observatorio
sirio de derechos humanos que nos da la
siguiente cifras 12 años de guerra ha
dejado al menos 613.000 personas
fallecidas de ellos
162.390 han sido civiles y de este grupo
25.546 han sido menores de edad el resto
es decir
340.674 han sido actores armados que han
perdido su vida en diferentes combates
2,1 millones de personas han resultado
heridas a lo largo de estos 12 años de
conflicto en Siria como decía esta
guerra involucró a múltiples actores
recordemos Quiénes están inmersos en
este conflicto primero Pues el gobierno
sirio y su ejército que es liderado por
el presidente basharasad que reprimió
estas manifestaciones pacíficas cuya
violencia dio paso entonces a esta
guerra civil y se enfrentó a los
Rebeldes sirios que sería entonces
nuestro segundo actor involucrado
también el autodenominado estado
islámico que aprovechó todo el caos que
había en Siria Se llegó hasta allí para
ganar territorio para poder proclamar su
ansiado califato También tenemos a los
kurdos agrupados en las unidades de
protección popular que son las milicias
armadas del partido de la unión
democrática que es la digamos la rama
Siria del partido de los trabajadores
del kurdistán de Turquía también está
Rusia que da total apoyo al gobierno
sirio y también lo están Irán que apoyan
también al gobierno sirio lo hacen por
simplemente garantizar la seguridad
geopolítica y la influencia que tiene
Irán en la zona de medio oriente hay que
decir que Siria es el principal socio de
Irán en el mundo islámico incluso
después de 12 años de guerra también
están Estados Unidos y la coalición
internacional que está compuesta por 60
países que se aliaron con las milicias
curvas para poder combatir al estado
islámico y hacer también contrapeso a
Rusia también se involucran este
conflicto Turquía un país vecino con una
historia en común con Siria y que se
involu cró ante el avance de las
milicias kurdas que no son bien vistas
por el gobierno de nacara también ante
los millones de migrantes que estaban
llegando a través de sus fronteras y por
supuesto para mantener intereses
regionales y las protección y la
protección de sus fronteras finalmente
tenemos a un acto regional y es Israel
que oficialmente no se ha involucrado en
este conflicto siempre ha dicho que es
neutral pero en diferentes ocasiones a
bombardeado posiciones de gisbola y de
las fuerzas iraníes por considerarlas
como una amenaza
habiendo entonces actualizado este
contexto de lo que pasa en Siria y de
quienes están involucrados en este
conflicto a lo largo de esta década pues
hoy en el debate de France 24 analizamos
Cómo está la situación en este país como
están las posiciones de los actores y
también planteamos esa pregunta básica
que muchos se hacen a esta hora
terminará el conflicto Habrá Paz en
Siria en el corto mediano plazo lo vamos
a conversar con nuestros invitados ellos
son se los presento a continuación
Carlos Alberto Patiño profesor de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia Es
doctor en filosofía e historia es
experto en conflictos internacionales
contemporáneos y en guerras del siglo
XXI también está con nosotros Mauricio
Jaramillo jacid él es analista
internacional y también es profesor de
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad El Rosario que está ubicada
en la ciudad de Bogotá en la capital
colombiana nuestros televidentes ustedes
ya lo saben pero se los recuerdo ustedes
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales nos encuentran en
Twitter en Facebook en instagram estamos
como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta numeral el debate
f-24 y a mí me encuentran en Twitter
como arroba santilogo rápidamente para
terminar esta introducción les recuerdo
que también todos los contenidos del
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
le doy entonces la bienvenida a Carlos
Alberto Patiño Gracias por estar con
nosotros Carlos Alberto como siempre Un
gusto tenerlo en el programa y El Punto
de partida la primera pregunta para este
análisis y este debate doce años de
guerra en Siria y porque este conflicto
parece haberse estancado y también
olvidado podemos decirlo por parte de la
comunidad internacional bienvenido
Hola buenas noches realmente creo que es
un conflicto muy complejo No creo que la
comunidad internacional se haya olvidado
de ese conflicto sino que ha quedado de
alguna manera sepultado por otra serie
de conflictos entre otros actualmente la
guerra en Ucrania y esto ha hecho que se
pierdan algunos fenómenos digamos de
perspectiva frente a la guerra en Siria
Ahora yo aclararía que la guerra en
Siria es mucho más compleja que una
guerra civil es una guerra de alguna
parte intraconfesional dentro del
islamismo entre diversas de vertientes
del islam diversas vertientes dentro del
surismo de diversas vertientes dentro
del sismo Pero adicionalmente hay una
digamos discusión muy importante también
infracciones muy importantes en contra y
a favor del gobierno de bachata y frente
a esta perspectiva de Qué significa el
régimen de los de en el contexto de
Siria Más allá de este asunto hay otro
elemento que es muy importante y es que
bachar de ninguna forma desde 2019
apoyado por Rusia específicamente por la
Aviación rusa y por la Infantería rusa
declaró la victoria en el conflicto
interno y finalmente se supondría que
Siria después de la eliminación del
califato y después de la eliminación de
El último autoproclamado califa a el
bagdaddy se supone que podría haber
creado una especie de condición de
control territorial sin embargo real la
realidad sobre el terreno es muy lejos
muy distante de esa posibilidad de
control territorial Siria Podría tener Y
de alguna forma la competencia
geopolítica además con respecto a
Turquía dicho respecto al al mundo del
kurdistán pues se mantiene vigente en
este contexto es muy difícil todavía
pensar que lo que conocíamos como Siria
o el territorio que entenderíamos que
era que sería Siria va a mantenerse en
pie y unificado y pues una manera de
verlo ha sido el terremoto que vimos
hace más o menos un mes ya demostrado
que aquellas zonas del terremoto que
fueron afectadas por la zona Rebeldes o
en las zonas no controladas por el
gobierno pues han quedado por fuera de
las posibilidades de una empresa
internacional humanitaria bueno bastante
Clara esa explicación pero démosle
también la palabra Mauricio Jaramillo le
doy también la bienvenida al programa
Mauricio un gusto tenerlo con nosotros y
el mismo Punto de partida 12 años de
guerra un conflicto estancado sí o no y
olvidado por la comunidad internacional
sí o no Cuál es su opinión
con las buenas tardes Santiago Un saludo
para para ti y para mi colega Carlos
Patiño
obviamente es un conflicto actualmente
olvidado Y esto es más grave por dos
razones en primer lugar porque el
conflicto en Siria
si bien comienza como tú lo mencionas
con una serie de protestas
hace un poco más de una década es un
conflicto que en el que tiene muchísima
responsabilidad de occidente por haber
alterado el equilibrio entre el mundo
sunita y el mundo Chita en nuestro
platillo tiene razón que esto es una
guerra entre clanes entre religiones
entre facciones de la misma religión
pero pues en buena medida aquí cuando
Estados Unidos invade Irak altera el
equilibrio que hay entre el mundo sunita
el mundo chinita con el vacío de poder
dejado por Sadam hussein lo que ocurre
básicamente en la zona es que en el
escenario iraquí en Siria en yemen y en
algunos estados del norte del África lo
que va a estallar es una guerra
fratricida entre los entre las dos
versiones del islam el islam sunita el
islam acordémonos que cuando Estados
Unidos derroca a San José Arabia saudí
que es el actualmente líder del mundo
sunita empieza a formar milicias
aprovechando un poco el desorden que hay
en Irak y muchas de Esas milicias son
las que van a lanzar esta guerra civil
en Siria entonces hay una guerra que yo
creo que es civil y hay una suerte de
Santiago como de guerra fría entre
terceros estados que han utilizado el
territorio iraquí el territorio sirio y
el territorio yemení para ejercer
influencia estos estados son como bien
lo mencionaban hace un rato Rusia de un
lado que es cercana tiene ascendencia
sobre Siria de sobre Irán Siria Irán y
de otro lado está Turquía a quien no le
interesa que gane que Hacienda que ganó
en espacios el islam cita Estados Unidos
algunos países europeos y obviamente
Arabia saudí el conflicto ahora
desafortunadamente está olvidado en
buena medida por por la guerra nuclear y
la guerra en Ucrania Si se quiere
eclipsado otras situaciones de de
conflictividad como la de como la de
yemen y esto insisto agrava la situación
porque le permite abachar a la Sad
seguir consolidando su poder seguir
violando los derechos humanos y
básicamente lo que podemos ver Es un
interés tremendamente selectivo de la
comunidad internacional por Siria
Mauricio continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa qué tal parece que
el mundo o por lo menos la comunidad
internacional se niega a entender una
realidad que hay en terreno que haya en
Siria no lo quiero llamar como una
realidad impuesta por parte de Siria de
alasad y sus aliados Pero hay una
realidad y es que al azar se mantiene en
el poder sigue siendo el presidente de
Siria además ganó gran parte del terreno
o recuperó gran parte del terreno de el
país pero también hay una realidad y son
estos grupos Rebeldes que controlan
parte del Norte cerca hay Li p en la
frontera con Turquía y también la
posición que tienen las milicias curvas
en esa parte del Norte hacia el noreste
de Siria que también está en manos de
ellos el país prácticamente está
repartido pero la comunidad
internacional no ve esto como un fin de
la guerra como que se repartieron
posiciones y este este conflicto podría
volver a escalar en cualquier momento
como lo vio usted
yo creo que a la comunidad internacional
le interesaba y por eso de golpe casi
que de carambola Estados Unidos y Rusia
estuvieron Del mismo lado lo que les
interesaba concretamente era vencer a
daesh era vencer al estado islámico Por
eso yo decía el estado islámico nació en
buena medida con el vacío de poder post
San José en Irak en este momento como no
hay una violencia De que vincule
concretamente al estado islámico hace
mucho tiempo no hay atentados
terroristas en Europa hace mucho tiempo
no tenemos una violencia en otras partes
del mundo que llame la atención de las
grandes capitales del mundo en occidente
pues esto ha hecho básicamente que haya
un desinterés Entonces el desinterés que
hay en el caso de Siria termina por
afectar a los kurdos a los que se les de
nuevo prometió de alguna manera
autonomía en toda esta Euforia de la
necesidad de contrarrestar El Avance del
estado islámico
y básicamente lo que hicieron fue una
vez si se quiere contenido
nunca lo mencionan del todo lo que
hicieron fue básicamente Santiago
correrlo empujarlo hacia el norte del
África y hoy por ejemplo es mucho más
poderoso en algunos estados de la zona
del sael como son burkina faso chat
Camerún acordémonos que hace un año y
medio asesinaron al presidente y debí de
chat y esto habla de una zona
enormemente vulnerable respecto al
terrorismo en el sael y que está
sufriendo las consecuencias de esa de
ese empuje de movimientos terroristas
entonces claro sería eso un polvorín con
el agravante que es un polvorín que hoy
no llama la atención de la comunidad
internacional ni siquiera había
consensos respecto hacia dejar o no en
el poder avanzar y un poco lo que se lo
que se terminó por pactar es que bachard
era un mal necesario
realmente al estado islámico claro
Carlos Alberto su opinión sobre esta
repartición territorial que hay en este
momento como están las fichas en este
momento vayan al azar con una ventaja
territorial contra los Rebeldes kurdos o
las milicias curvas y Los Rebeldes
sirios con el norte del país
prácticamente repartido este esta
configuración puede llevarnos a un
futuro a una desintegración del estado
sirio como tal o a que se esté gestando
allí las bases para una nueva escalada
de este conflicto
Pues la verdad Bueno quiero aprovechar a
saludar a Mauricio pero más allá de eso
quiero también subrayar que que en la
realidad estamos frente a una situación
muy compleja de Sí en realidad el estado
sirio tiene como subsistir Más allá del
actual circunstancia Incluso si el
estado sirio podría subsistir Más allá
del apoyo militar ruso aquí hay que
recordar que Estados Unidos desde la
presidencia Barack Obama puso todo para
que bachar las afueras de rock derrocado
y fuera Derrotado entre otras por el
ejército libre sirio eh sin una
propuesta Clara en términos políticos de
reordenamiento del régimen sirio o de
ordenamiento territorial y con un claro
enemigo que es Turquía y obviamente con
una especie de apoyo envenenado que es
el de Irán eh además que es un apoyo
envenenado frente a una minoría que La
minoría gobernante que es La minoría
alauta en esa perspectiva Siria enfrenta
pues fenómenos realmente muy complicados
primero Cómo crear una especie de
continuidad y continuidad territorial
frente a desafíos realmente serios en
términos militares el otro asunto que es
muy importante es Siria logrará mantener
una unidad de régimen O sí determinará
desintegrado en ese contexto frente a la
posibilidad política de lo que podría
ser digamos una especie de Siria en el
contexto de la posguerra y mucho más
allá de este asunto en la medida en que
Rusia se vea más implicada en la guerra
en Ucrania Pues será más difícil que se
pueda mantener en pie sin contar con un
apoyo decisivo de Vladimir Putin en ese
contexto Pues resulta ser realmente muy
complicado de tener claro Qué significa
una Siria en el contexto contemporáneo
Carlos justamente tenemos en pantalla
esas imágenes del encuentro entre el
presidente de Siria bachar al azar y su
homólogo de Rusia Vladimir Putin países
aliados en el marco de estos doce años
qué tan significativa es Esta visita de
Salazar a Moscú cuando en el país pues
hay manifestaciones en iblic en el norte
y Y esa calma saco esta frase de caja de
cajón para decirla densa calma que reina
en todo el país en el marco de estos 12
años
habría que recordar que realmente es
Rusia la que le otorga a la Sad la
victoria militar en gran parte del
territorio Y en este contexto estas
imágenes estamos viendo son imágenes de
una verdadera Alianza política de alguna
manera sin límites entre Siria y Rusia
de hecho Siria es uno de los pocos
países que apoyan ilimitadamente a Rusia
junto con Corea del Norte Pakistán
etcétera y Bielorrusia y en ese contexto
pues esto trae digamos una consecuencia
absolutamente real en términos
geopolíticos Y es que Rusia Apuesta por
Siria de forma contundente Aunque la
guerra en Ucrania esté implicando una
consecuencia seria de pervivencia del
régimen de bazar realmente basar de a lo
largo de este año 2023 está pasando por
una crisis política de fondo mucho más
contundente en el sentido de la
supervivencia estratégica del régimen
mucho más allá de los acuerdos políticos
o de las posibilidades que tenga para
maniobrar para mantenerse en pie dentro
del poder dentro de Siria Mauricio su
opinión sobre este encuentro entre el
presidente de bazar a la Sad y el
presidente Vladimir Putin y uno puede
entender la sintonía que hay en términos
políticos entre ambos países pero dado
el contexto en el que estamos ahora con
la Guerra de Ucrania qué tan relevante
es para Rusia la amistad o cercanía con
Siria qué tan relevante es Siria en este
momento para el kremlin un país que está
completamente arrasado devastado con una
crisis humanitaria
como lo decíamos de las más importantes
en el mundo y fuera de eso con una parte
del Norte del país devastado por los
terremotos de hace unas semanas
Bueno lo primero que hay que mencionar
Es que para para Rusia Siria ese
mantener un poco el prestigio esto viene
desde la unión soviética es decir la
alianza muscuidamasco
sobrepasa largamente a abachar las
hallas Vladimir Putin y tiene que ver
con el padre jafet que fue un Aliado de
los soviéticos y fue de las pocas
relaciones de las pocas alianzas que
sobrevivió al al fin de la guerra fría y
está la base además de tartús Es decir
para Rusia es muy importante porque si
se quiere su Aliado más más relevante y
más significativo en el medio oriente
respecto de Siria Siria es un estado
sobre el cual hace mucho tiempo se ha
especulado acerca de de su viabilidad
como decía ahorita el profesor Patiño en
el 2006 por ejemplo cuando hubo la
revolución del Cedro en el Líbano que
terminó teniendo por efecto la salida de
los servicios de inteligencia sirios en
el Líbano se habló de unas de las peores
crisis en Siria luego vino la guerra
civil y a esas dos coyunturas ha
Sobreviviendo en Vallarta Entonces yo
pensaría que no digamos yo no tendría
dudas acerca de la viabilidad del estado
sirio creo que nos podemos preguntar
acerca de la viabilidad más bien de
Estados en el cinturón del sael que
están sufriendo hoy La amenaza
terrorista pero yo pienso que la mayoría
de Estados árabes tienen un poco Este
modelo autoritario tienen por lo menos
fuerza pública tienen fuerzas armadas
Obviamente el sentido de unidad está
todavía en construcción y y lo a lo que
se aspira y lo ideal acá es que haya por
lo menos un consenso mínimo en la
comunidad internacional es que como
ocurrió tanto en el Líbano como en Irak
haya un modelo de democracia
consociativa es decir donde las
diferentes comunidades puedan tener una
participación porque básicamente lo que
yo creo que está eclosionando lo que
está estallando hoy en Siria es este
modelo en el que una minoría La minoría
al agüita concentrar poder como ocurrió
en su momento en el Irak de samus en
cuando una minoría es unita Por más
laico que fuera el estado como en el
caso de Siria que también es un estado
muy muy parecido laico pues concentraba
ese poder en detrimento de las otras
comunidades yo creo que esto básicamente
es es una cosa es que sea inviable el
modelo actual de bachard Y si hablaba
muchísimo de la transición y otra cosa
es que se sea inviable el modelo de
estado Ciro y yo creo que el estado
sirio seguirá siendo viable por mucho
tiempo claro Carlos hay algo que todavía
a mí no me queda claro y es que en todos
estos movimientos de fichas a nivel
internacional uno de los argumentos del
presidente Putin para llevar a cabo la
invasión del territorio ucraniano fue
que querían provocar un nuevo orden
internacional un nuevo escenario
internacional en donde Rusia sea más
tenida en cuenta en ese orden de ideas y
si usted tal vez entiende un poco más
cómo es ese orden internacional que
pretende establecer el presidente Putin
hay que ficha clave o qué representa
Siria en ese orden mundial
Pues realmente Siria representa a algo
que es muy interesante desde la Rusia
del siglo 18 y es la posibilidad de
concretar la llegada de Rusia a los que
los estrategas rusas del siglo 18
llamaban los mares calientes que son los
mares del Mediterráneo Oriental y allí
desde el periodo soviético hay algo que
es fundamental que es la base de tartus
que antes de la guerra de Siria tenía
menos de trescientos marineros rusos y
que desde el año 2012-2013 tiene más de
entre seis mil y seis mil quinientos más
dineros rusos además de una serie de
áreas en las cuales ha pasado la
aviación de combate rusa y además una
serie de unidades de Infantería
importantes en este contexto Siria
representa una posibilidad de digamos
puentear o pasar por encima de Turquía y
obviamente representa un desafío real
sobre Turquía sobre esas ambiciones
rusas de Rusia desde el presencia en él
el Mediterráneo Oriental esto insisto es
muy importante y hay que tenerlo Claro
que ha sido un objetivo de ruso desde
mediados del siglo XIX no es un fenómeno
contemporáneo y en ese contexto para
Rusia su Alianza con Siria que además
explica toda la el apoyo del periodo
soviético a los a los de ha sido
fundamental para tener una presencia en
esta zona claro y viniendo un poco más a
la actualidad tenemos unos hechos
recientes que también han modificado un
poco el escenario allí en Siria justo
para el marco de esta conmemoración de
los 12 años y son los recientes
terremotos en la parte Norte del país
que volvieron a poner en la escena
internacional a este país la crisis
humanitaria y sobre todo volvieron a
poner en el escenario internacional
Mauricio al presidente bachar alazad
esto como lo ha logrado manejar el
presidente al azar este remesón que no
solamente fue el de los temblores sino a
nivel político que le ha vuelto a dar
pantalla a nivel internacional para
volver a traer la atención sobre lo que
está pasando allí 12 años después Él
sigue en el poder pero ahora jugando con
algunas piezas A favor o cómo lo ve
usted
sin duda alguna el terremoto le terminó
devolviendo a Siria el protagonismo
Internacional que había perdido en el
último tiempo yo la verdad no creo que
el terremoto ni aporte ni le resta
legitimidad a echarlas a Yo pienso que
son son los problemas distintos el el
problema de la legitimidad de Vallarta
es doble es interno básicamente porque
hay unos segmentos poblacionales
representativos que no reconocen Su
autoridad y que veían en el ascenso de
estos movimientos terroristas una
oportunidad básicamente para para
derrocarlo y para imponer un nuevo orden
y si tenían apoyo internacional pues aún
mejor y tiene un problema de legitimidad
internacional ahora que se suma un poco
por por la pérdida de terrenos de
espacios internacionales que tiene Rusia
hoy un poco los quienes aparecen como
aliados de Rusia parecerían esta
aislados internacionalmente una cosa por
ejemplo es china que ha mantenido una
neutralidad incluso ha propuesto un pan
de paz un plan de paz Perdón hablado de
que las partes era negociar y otra cosa
es los estados que han optado por apoyar
efusivamente a Rusia como Venezuela como
Cuba como la misma Siria entonces aquí
en términos de legitimidad el terremoto
no cambia la correlación de fuerzas y yo
pensaría que Siria sigue siendo Santiago
importantísima para Rusia no no
solamente por lo que acaba de mencionar
el profesor Patiño con quien coincido
sino porque hay que entender que el plan
ruso es ser incidente en temas vitales
para la seguridad mundial sería Corea
del Norte Irán la guerra global contra
el terrorismo son muchos frentes en los
que hoy el mundo depende de Rusia
Entonces en ese en ese orden de ideas en
ese ajedrez si se quieren ese mapa
geopolítico yo creo que sería es una
ficha de muchas pero no creo que sea la
más relevante y menos aún hoy con la
guerra en Ucrania
y Mauricio Perdón Carlos Alberto Cuál es
su opinión sobre este digamos este
segundo aire que está tomando el
mandatario sirio a nivel internacional
lo vimos Estableciendo relaciones de
nuevo incluso con algunos países de el
mundo árabe del mundo musulmán que vale
la pena destacar cómo es esa relación de
Siria con los otros Países Árabes
cercanos
Bueno pues la verdad es que es que el
terremoto ha servido para que
establezca una un principio pragmático
de relación con otros estados árabes
pero también a la vez establezca una
especie de condición pragmática frente a
a otras zonas a otros territorios
digamos distintos y en ese contexto
habría que decir que esto ha permitido
que de alguna forma el descongelamiento
por ejemplo las relaciones recientes de
Arabia Saudita Irán o el acercamiento de
Israel algunos Países Árabes o el
acercamiento cuando Egipto le permita
basar una mayor maniobra más importante
frente a cómo se reacomoda entre los
Países Árabes pero también como mantiene
el apoyo de Irán lo que además quiero
digamos subrayar Aquí hay una especie de
geopolítica islámica que se nos escapa
un poco en sus detalles pero que
realmente es muy activa es muy
importante frente a los mecanismos en
los que actúa esa geopolítica islámica
en esa perspectiva basaron ha sido
bastante pragmático ha sido mucho más
digamos hábil de lo que algunos medios
occidentales suelen creer y realmente
basarlas Ha logrado permanecer en el
poder pese a estos a estos más de 12
años de guerra y ha logrado permanecer
en el poder de una manera pues que de
alguna forma hace que sea el referente
para el merecimiento de una especie de
régimen de Siria tradicional y de
Concepción de esas fronteras que habían
sido definidas o por lo menos
reconocidas desde el final de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial Carlos así las cosas
Me parece que entonces la teoría del
presidente bazar al azar funcionó Y
triunfó esa teoría de El caos en Siria o
yo él se mantiene en el poder triunfo
esta teoría es que es que Mauricio le
decía ahora con Claridad una de las
grandes consecuencias del derrocamiento
que Estados Unidos hizo de el régimen de
San José y en esto no quiero ni aparecer
validando ni diciendo que San José fuera
una buena persona o un buen gobernante
Don José ahí fue realmente un dictador
absolutamente tenebroso y terrible pero
una de las grandes consecuencias es que
a ese dictador tenebroso y terrible la
caída pudo haber sido incluso ha sido
peor que el mantenimiento de San José es
decir la desaparición de régimen de
husein pareciera ser a veces incluso más
grave que el mantenimiento de José mismo
y en este contexto incluso terminó
dándole más poder a uno de los grandes
enemigos de Estados Unidos Irán que lo
que representaba Irak en sí mismo en esa
misma perspectiva la desaparición de
Vallarta puede tener siendo un
experimento incluso peor que el
mantenimiento en el poder cosa Que
obviamente es una especie de pacto con
el demonio y una especie de pacto
absolutamente terrible con asuntos
absolutamente calamitosos e
impresentables desde un punto de vista
del Amor al público claro Mauricio en
estos 12 años el papel de los diferentes
actores internacionales que yo
mencionaba en la introducción del
programa ha cambiado no solamente porque
el contexto de la guerra ha ido
cambiando con el paso del tiempo sino
también porque la realidad de estos
actores ha cambiado Cómo está ahora el
papel de países como por ejemplo Turquía
fundamental en este conflicto de otros
países como Irán Incluso el mismo Israel
que yo mencionaba que no es un país que
se ha involucrado de lleno en la guerra
pero que ha tenido que actuar porque
considera una amenaza algunos avances de
Irán y de hisbola en territorio sirio y
también pues vale la pena analizar el
papel de Estados Unidos hoy 12 años
después en que están estos países en el
conflicto de Siria
es muy difícil determinarlo una cosa es
y yo estoy de acuerdo con lo que plantea
el profesor Patiño la geopolítica de la
zona una cosa es esta política de
alianzas las competencias que hay
recientemente por ejemplo hay un revés
importantísimo para para Israel en favor
del mundo árabe y musulmán con el
restablecimiento de relaciones entre
Irán y Arabia saudí apadrinados por por
china entonces lo que estamos viendo Son
un montón de movimientos pero yo creo
que esta geopolítica no tiene mucha
incidencia en el conflicto interno o en
la guerra civil Siria el involucramiento
por ejemplo de Estados Unidos de Turquía
de Francia Reino Unido
Irán Rusia no tiene mucho que ver con
con la transición la transición
solamente depende de la correlación de
fuerzas que hay en Siria que en este
momento favorece ampliamente a avanzar
la sal porque es poco probable que haya
un cambio fundamental porque no le
interesa a ninguno de sus actores que tú
has mencionado Santiago y además porque
se desvalorizó un poco esta idea de la
transición y el cambio cuando uno ve por
ejemplo la caída de la sismo te aplica
en Argelia Omar albacil en Sudán benalí
en en túnez en Egipto en ninguno de esos
casos por ejemplo prosperó la democracia
gadafi por ejemplo en Libia y en casi
todo subo más bien un territorio de Caos
y mayor inestabilidad regional entonces
creo que un poco la el cálculo que han
hecho buena parte de sus actores sea
Turquía sea Estados Unidos sea Francia
Reino Unido es básicamente un cambio
estructural
en un país como Siria puede llegar a
tener unas implicaciones no solamente
sobre la región de oriente medio sino
sobre el norte de África y en este
momento de guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania
creo que a nadie le interesa alterar ese
equilibrio por eso es tan difícil que
haya voluntad política e incidencia
directa en la relación interna en Siria
no hay cambios fundamentales 12 años
después y viendo las manifestaciones de
la jornada de hoy en it lip los reclamos
siguen siendo básicamente los mismos
derecho a poder votar a poder elegir y
el fin del gobierno de bazar a la Sad en
Siria Ya llegamos al bloque final Carlos
Alberto quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que puede venir para
este conflicto ya lo decía yo no hay
cambios sustanciales los reclamos siguen
siendo los mismos las figuras siguen
siendo prácticamente los mismos los
actores igual qué va a pasar entonces en
Siria porque va a estar al azar no es
eterno en algún momento tendrá que dejar
Siria Pero
qué va a pasar con el país un proceso de
paz una una un desescalamiento del
conflicto o esto se va a quedar así una
guerra abierta
Pues la verdad es que por ahora no es
posible pensar en un proceso de paz esto
es absolutamente impensable no hay con
quien negociar no hay una agenda de
negociaciones y e incluso la idea misma
de países de Siria como país está en un
serio cuestionamiento y no pareciera ser
que hubiese una especie de debate de
fondo frente a lo que significaría el
país o la condición del país en sí mismo
y eso pues obviamente trae una
dificultad muy seria para de imaginarse
o pensar qué significaría el
mantenimiento de Siria de hecho
pareciera ser que estamos frente a un
conflicto de larga duración pero de baja
intensidad que No necesariamente
garantiza el mantenimiento de la unidad
territorial y Mauricio su conclusión
no básicamente no hay ningún estímulo
regional creo que a la comunidad
internacional hoy no le interesa que
haya un cambio en la correlación de
fuerzas en Siria Me parece que ese
momento ya pasó ocurrió Si se quiere
2011-2013 incluso con con esta Primavera
árabe pero creo que el resultado de la
primavera árabe es suficientemente
descorazonador poco prometedor no hubo
ningún caso ni siquiera túnez y viendo
un poco lo que ha hecho que uno se da
cuenta que efectivamente en ningún caso
prosperó la democracia esto a mi juicio
ha desvalorizado la idea de una
transición en Siria Entonces cuando lo
veo un poco la correlación de fuerzas
internas cuando uno ve los ánimos y y
básicamente la posición de la mayoría de
potencias influyentes tanto extra
regionales como regionales uno se da
cuenta que no hay
ninguna ningún elemento ningún indicio
de que vaya a haber un cambio
fundamental en Siria y pues
efectivamente vamos a asistir a un a un
conflicto de baja intensidad que
seguramente se va a prolongar el tiempo
va a ser la no es una persona vieja
sobrevivir insisto a coyunturas como la
la revolución del Cedro y esta guerra
civil hablan de un presidente que
todavía tiene largo rato en el poder
este un par de minutos todavía alcanzo a
hacerles Una última pregunta y ya que
usted toca el tema de la primavera árabe
Siria esta guerra en Siria es
consecuencia y tiene lugar en ese marco
de esas revueltas populares en
diferentes países en el norte de África
del medio oriente esto fueron
revoluciones fallidas ningún país logró
establecer la democracia si se entiende
que estos países querían adoptar la
democracia de estilo occidental para
estos territorios y si es esta la
fórmula de gobierno Y de forma de vida
que que estos países necesitan usted
como la oe Mauricio
yo pensaría que son procesos a los que
hay que darles tiempo como cuando hubo
la revolución húngara en el 56 solamente
30 años después pudieron ver la
democracia lo mismo pasó con
Checoslovaquia o está Primavera de
plagas del 68 y solamente 15 20 años
después pudieron instalar la democracia
yo creo que los el mundo ahora necesita
de procesos aún más largos y y me parece
que hay que tener paciencia y entender
que esto es gradual y paulatino bueno
llevamos 12 años viendo esta guerra en
Siria Carlos Alberto su opinión no yo yo
realmente creo que aquí hay un asunto
muy complejo Y es que yo No sabría decir
si en realidad las primarias era una
especie de aspiración a llegar a las
democracias del estilo occidental y
incluso Por qué las primeras áreas se
dieron fundamentalmente en los regímenes
que tenían algún rasgos republicano pero
reforzaron a los regímenes de carácter
monárquico e incluso monarquías
absolutas como la monarquía Saudita o
otras monarquías distintas se han
mantenido bastante firmes y en ese
contexto pues se crea una situación muy
compleja frente a Qué podrían ser las
primarias
Pues a Carlos Alberto de Mauricio les
agradezco mucho por haber hecho este
análisis este balance doce años de
guerra en Siria a raíz de estas
protestas ciudadanas que nacieron en el
marco de la primavera árabe un conflicto
que sigue abierto como decía Carlos un
conflicto abierto pero de baja
intensidad que vamos a seguir analizando
aquí en el debate de Francia 24 Muchas
gracias por su análisis y por sus
comentarios es todo por hoy Les
agradezco su sintonía y En nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros hay que decir que la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Andrés doncell y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera ustedes pueden seguir dejando
todos sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales y por
supuesto sigan en sintonía de France 24
sigan con nosotros
[Música]